I am on the search for universal design
principles in a universal design
language which I know sounds outrageous
but I think it is rooted in something
bigger than any one individuals personal
expression so in 1977 George Nelson who
was the design director for Herman
Miller for 30 years wrote this book
called how to see his belief was that if
the world could learn to see it would be
a happier place and he did it really
with a great sense of humor so I'm gonna
read just one little paragraph here to
you he says people who buy things make
decisions on the basis of whether or not
they like the design since they rarely
have any way of knowing how well the
product will work after they get at home
the trouble with such design decisions
is that visual illiterates have no way
of knowing whether a design is good or
not and this is why the interiors of
most houses look as if they had been put
together by the blind
in fact most motel rooms are equally
tasteless a mediocre probably because
the management wants to customers to
relax in a familiar home-like
environment so what he was suggesting in
the book is that the world is filled
with visual pollution and that we were
all responsible for this it turns out
that the way George sees a is actually
rooted some scientific evidence that all
40 years later we're starting to
discover I want to unlock some of that
for you a couple of years ago I began
noticing some interesting psychological
studies in the news so here's one two
professors have found that we rent more
romance films when it's cold outside and
they believe it's because it's a search
for emotional warmth that somehow in our
minds we work waiting physical warmth
and emotional warmth together
researchers found that momentarily
holding a warm cup of coffee caused us
to consider others strangers warm
friendly people
and the inverse was true as well one
more study for you this one University
of Amsterdam
so they took two groups and gave them a
task one group was given a clipboard
that was lightweight one was given a
clipboard that was heavy and the group
that had the heavy clipboard took the
job more serious
we in the group the light clipboard
somehow they were equating the heaviness
with importance and value so that weight
equaled value and that tactile sensation
actually influenced their decision
making these studies and a lot more like
them are correlating emotions there are
five senses and language metaphors and
that caught my attention I mean I I
thought of language metaphor as a poetic
device you know it is an instrument that
we use to describe experiencial things I
had never realized that they might be
revealing something about human
experience or the way we understand the
world interestingly during the same
decade that George Nelson wrote how to
see there was this debate going on about
the origin of language Noam Chomsky had
a student named George Lake off the
theory at the time was that language is
inherent in humanity and we generate
language from our being and lake Hoff
said I don't know I I think it's more
about generated from our experience and
our experience dictates how we create
language but in the end Lake Hoff did
have enough evidence to prove a theory
and that theory was that human
experience creates language and he did
it through metaphor he wrote a book in
1980 called metaphors we lived by it
shows a how visceral experience creates
language rather than disembodied reason
creating language and that idea is most
elegantly illustrated through language
metaphor so this made me wonder if if
our understanding of metaphor is useful
for inspiration for design I wondered
that so I asked George Lakoff I wrote a
minute said hey I kind of understand
you're three like this I'm thinking
about what metaphor means for design and
how we as designers talk about how a
design might be strong or warm or busy
do you think there's a connection here
and and is it something interesting and
George wrote back and said yeah I think
that is it's a very reasonable
connection so you guys all probably live
by Cartier
in theory Cartesian theory is basically
the mind in the body are separate
rational thinking is the kind of
thinking then we shall adhere to in
emotional thinking is what we should all
reject in reality we know we don't live
that way at all where we have a very
intertwined life and this Cartesian
theory has been with us for a long time
now and and I think especially in the
business world we struggle with it all
the time and there's very little
discussion about the aesthetic value of
what you're doing or the rich but you're
giving the world so I think it's
actually ignoring the deep unspoken
appeal of design when we when we just
say emotions don't matter brain imaging
tools show that when we experience
something or we imagine something the
same regions of our mind are being
activated so for example if I'm thinking
about cold weather or I'm thinking about
a callous person the region of the brain
that connects those two words that cold
word together is connected and so the
implication is that whether you're
imagining something or you're taking
action to the brain it's all the same
and I think this is why it matters to
design it turns out that metaphors
weather visual or spoken are triggering
imagination and they are tools that we
as creators can use to make the world
better and make experiences better so
there's a still to say called embodied
cognition another term for its physical
intelligence the idea that we're
understanding with our bodies that our
five senses are giving us the key to
unlocking the world and so a number of
us I do we're confident in these
theories and said let's try to map some
of these things out and make tools that
we could share to either give designers
more confidence in their own intuition
or to help our clients understand the
values that we have so we made a map and
we base them off the five senses let's
look at fresh so fresh can be understood
via sight and sound and we can connect
freshness with concepts like new and
healthy and young I think you know this
is true from your own personal
experience which Apple would you like to
eat I think most of us would choose the
healthy one
we actually used this very slide in a
client meeting when we're having trouble
getting the client to invest in new
manufacturing processes we showed this
to the boardroom I asked him the same
question they all said they would like
meet the healthy apple as well from that
point we got them to invest in the new
manufacturing equipment so that was
really great because all I did was show
them two apples all right they have to
show any spreadsheets it was yeah and it
worked and I want to show you the
difference in the designs here so these
are two mattresses but the design in the
front you can see as much crisper
plumper fuller than design in the back
which is what they previously had
another example this one also based on
fruit a startup called Axio came to us
and said they would like us to help them
redesign their hardware design language
their interactions in their brand and so
we said okay your name Zac so you sound
like a villain maybe we should
reconsider that since the product was
actually helping people understand their
brainwaves and find focus and flow be
able to track that with a headband be
able to connect that via bluetooth to
your iPhone so we renamed the melon much
friendlier I'm much more approachable
you can start to see how that idea of
focus and structure can be built into
those beautiful colors from the melon
it's juicy something's confident and
quiet another one will look at the root
metaphor of old old can be positive or
negative I think is actually a very
positive thing so surviving time
enduring showing marks creating a diary
and I think that sounds a lot like your
favorite pair of Chuck Taylors probably
so when we designed the retail flagship
store for converse we brought those
ideas into the store so that the floor
would wear a certain way so that the
bleachers which show marks so that it
felt worn in not worn out so it turns
out the way George saw the world is the
way we can all see the world and the way
George Lake Hoff heard it is how we can
all hear it and so we've come full
circle connecting the ideas of two
visionaries with the art and science a
visual literacy so my parting thought to
you is if anything I said to you today
sounds important it was probably the
slides with the heavy font they
you